يسعد صباحك اهلا وسهلا بك معنا في صباح
العربيه استاذ علي استاذ علي اولا بنقلك
الحمد لله على السلامه ما بعرف اذا استاذ
علي معنا سمعنا حمد لله على السلامه يا
استاذ
الف سلامه لايناس الله يسلمكم اكيد مثل
هيك اخبار يعني بتفرحنا واكيد انتم الاساس
اللي بتفرحكم يعني تشوف بنتك فلدت كبدك
اليوم
سويه وسليمه ايضا في ظهرها بس بالاساس انا
حابه اعرف يعني هذا المرض النادر والخطير
كما وصف كيف جاء لايناس بالاساس
أول صباح الخير على صباح العربيه صباح
الورد
ونحن بنحييك الاخت سهام والاخت نادين
والدكتور القامه
ومفخره السعاده يعني بالنسبه لكل المرضى
والناس في بلدي وفي كل البلدان
اهلا بك بالنسبه لايناس
الحمد لله بالنسبه لايناس يعني فرحه لا
تتصور ايناس يعني فتره بتاعه سنه ونص لا
تنام مثل
اخواتها ايناس فتره سنه ونص حتى الاكل ما
بتاكل كويس ايناس في كل حياتها يعني كانت
توقف بسبب المرض ولكن بفضل الدكتور والحمد
لله الان ايناس بصحه جيده وان شاء الله
ربنا يقبل الصحه الى ابعد مما نكون ان شاء
الله نعم
طيب استاذ علي اليوم كمان بس بدنا نعرف
انت كنت عايش مع ايناس كل الوقت كيف كان
وضعها مثلا كيف كانت تمشي تدبر امور
حياتها اليوميه بهذا الوضع الصعب وهذا
التحدب
ايناس هي هي قويه الحمد لله
ويعني كانت حياه صعبه جدا ايناس كانت في
الشارع يعني عندما نذهب الى ونحن في
الاطباء يعني كانت تنادى بانها معوقه
ايناس يعني عندما ياتينا الزميلات في
الدراسه للزياره كانت تبكي بعد الزياره
لان ترى ان هي خلاص قد توقفت عن
الدراسه
ايناس في كل حياته كانت صعبه جدا يعني خلي
بالك ان هي سنه ونص لا تنام على ظهرها سنه
ونص لا تاكل خوفا من الانحناء الخطير
فهي في فرحه جميله جدا وكونها هي من اخطر
العمليات في العمود الفقري
والحمد لله الحمد لله من قبل والحمد لله
من بعد اكيد ونحن نتمنى لها الف الف سلامه